thank you very much indeed uh Jonathan
yes the Department of Homeland Homeland
Security in the United States it's
saying today that it didn't see any
surge at the midnight moment when the
so-called title 42 ran out but what it
can deny is that there has been a record
surge Daily Record figures of migrants
crossing the border in the run-up to
that midnight moment when the law
changed now we've spent the day here in
New Mexico on the mountain that looms
large over the U.S Mexico border let's
have a look now at a day in the life of
Mount Crystal rain
a helicopter and to the right an officer
on Horseback conduct border patrol high
on Mount Crystal Ray where America meets
Mexico
with our cameras we found what they were
looking for migrants concealed among
rocks one in the middle watching us with
binoculars
they didn't care for the reverse angle
one throwing a stone at the Drone
by vehicle Border Patrol Chase reports
of migrants on the ground
while the helicopter continued its
search by air
and they kept coming
more
and yet more
it's easy to see why migrants would
choose this route to make a border
crossing much of the border is lined by
this a 21-foot high fence but take a
look here at this particular Point what
separates America from Mexico is
concrete a foot high
uh on the mountain where they couldn't
build a wall border crossing is a daily
routine and it's where migrants see a
clear path to the United States
a white marker high up denotes the U.S
border to be here is to see the
difficulty in stemming the flow of
immigration title 42 or not
when the old law passed U.S Homeland
Security said there had been no
substantial increase in migrant numbers
but they've acknowledged failings over
time our system has been broken for more
than two decades it was last reformed in
the 1990s so that is the first point the
second point is we have not received
from Congress the resources that we need
and that we requested it is a political
story that grows with the numbers
they kept on coming over Mount Crystal
Ray towards New Mexico
the Mountain's reminder that this is a
tale with people at its heart
well there you go it was a busy day that
was one sector of the border at New
Mexico and speak to border patrol
officers and they tell you that some
days they can be chasing up to 500
migrants and that's the day after title
42 so on the face of it here and it is a
microcosm there's no great change with
the law uh the challenge for Joe Biden
is considerable of course he is
reinforcing the message that there will
be tough new restrictions he's talking
about the expulsion of migrants who
don't apply for Asylum before they get
into the United States and who don't
apply online saying that they could be
expelled for five years and not allowed
to return if they do they could be
criminally prosecuted so that has
prompted a fear amongst migrants that
entry restrictions could be tougher
following the end of title 42 that
clearly has fueled a surge of sorts of
that we've seen in recent days and weeks
that's been compounded by misinformation
provided by human Smugglers so that is
the basis on which we have seen the
Practical experience here it is big on
politics clearly it will be one of the
defining issues of the coming election a
defining issue of the future for
President Joe Biden